welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Star Wars Episode nine the rise
of Skywalker concludes not just some
modern trilogy of films but the fool
Skywalker saga but a lot of happens in
this film and depending on how loudly
the guy next to you was sobbing sorry
about that by the way you might have
missed how exactly all the insanity in
this movie was possible look I know it's
a bit early not all of you saw it on
opening night so spoiler warning come on
I'm about to explain the dramatic ending
of this film you haven't seen the movie
it's totally okay to just pause right
now then go run off and see it and then
come right back okay so the final act of
the rises Skywalker is an epic battle on
the planets EXO call the homeworld of
these Sith in the unknown regions where
Emperor Palpatine has been secretly
resurrecting a fleet of stardestroyers
each equipped with Death Star super
lasers to reclaim his empire but how is
Palpatine back exactly the movies a bit
vague about it but Palpatine does tell
kylo in the opening scene I have died
before the dark side of the force is a
pathway to many abilities some time to
be unnatural which is they call back to
Palpatine story to Anakin in Revenge of
the Sith about death Plagueis the wise
his former sift master who taught him
the path to immortality dark side of the
force is a pathway to many abilities
some consider to be unnatural
unfortunately he taught his apprentice
everything he knew then his apprentice
killed him in his sleep in the scene we
also learned that Snoke in the voice of
Darth Vader were Palpatine pulling the
strings
[Music]
ever inside your
we see what looks like a GUI version of
smoke in like a gestation pod suggesting
some kind of unholy genetic
experimentation now when the rebels are
debating Palpatine's return Dominik
monoghan scare achter speculates that it
is dark science cloning secrets only the
Sith knew so sit Solberg incarnation
plus good old-fashioned Kamino flavored
clone in equals Palpatine's return but I
will dig more into Palpatine and his
whole return in its plan in another
video so Rey after learning that she's
Palpatine's granddaughter confronts
Palpatine in his ancient Sith ruins on
EXO Gul Palpatine is connected to like a
big crane maybe he's like on a
life-support device and he goads Rey
into striking him down so that his
spirit which contains all of the cysts
can possess her body and make her SIF
Empress but Rey denies him she drops her
lightsaber behind her back to kylo Ren
now Ben solo once more after Rey healed
him at the end of their duel on the
ruins of the Death Star and after Leia
gave her life force to her son so kylo
catches the lightsaber through their
force time connection because we know
that objects can like teleport between
that and he uses this lightsaber to
wreck the Knights of Ren and now
together ray and Ben wield these
lightsabers of Luke and Leia but
Palpatine overpowers them and uses SIF
lightning to wipe out the assembled
resistance fleet above Rey looks up to
the stars and hears the voices of Jedi
past including a you and McGregor as
obi-wan
you also hear ala kinescope ray Hayden
Christensen as Anakin Freddie Prinze jr.
as kanan jarrus and ashley eckstein as
ahsoka tano both from the animated
series and of course Luke and Leia's
voices and now with these spirits of all
the Jedi inside her Rey crosses both
lightsabers and deflects the Sith
Lightning back on Palpatine burning away
his body Raiders of the Lost Ark style
and wiping out all those SIF ghosts in
the arena behind her and depleting her
own energy but Ben rises up from the pit
and gives her his life force to heal her
returning that they burton for a moment
they're both alive and the kid but then
Ben rolls over and dies anything along
with his mother's body back on the
resistance base so the resistance fleet
destroys each Star Destroyer one by one
we see them all fall all over the galaxy
including Cloud City Endor Lucy wicked
another a walk celebrating and jakku the
resistance celebrates back on
class rape Owen thin triple hug Maz
Kanata finally gives Chewbacca the rebel
medallion that he was snubbed in the
first film
finally this medal was presumably hunts
in Lando asks Jana if she wants to find
out where she's from setting up a
possible spin-off and now finally we
arrive at our final scene with rey and
bb-8 visiting the lars moisture farm on
Tatooine where this saga began it's now
half buried in sand and ray sleds down a
dune calling back the opening shots of
her in the force awakens all while John
Williams Rey theme plays ray takes out
Luke and Leia's lightsabers and she
wraps them up and she uses the force to
bury them in the sand but then she
reveals a new lightsaber that she has
built for herself with a yellow blade
now this is significant to Star Wars
lore yellow lightsaber blades have been
associated with Jedi sentinels first
introduced in the video games
sentinels seek a balance between the
councilors and the guardians and they
wish to educate themselves on the more
practical aspects of life unlike others
that I order sentinels recognize that
the force is not the solution everything
maybe this suggests Ray's future as a
Jedi less bound to the Jedi Code one who
embraces practical skills instead of the
eternal battle between light and dark
traditionally the Kyber crystals that
power lightsabers only take on a color
once they have been gathered by a jedi
padawan they bond between the crystal
and the Jedi has formed as that
lightsaber is constructed so maybe this
yellow color paints ray as a whole new
kind of Jedi with a whole new outlook
and this theme of identity plays out in
the final lines an old woman calls out
to Rey saying no one has been on this
farm in ages and she asks who she is
rade looks out across the desert and in
the dusty wind she sees the force ghosts
of Luke and Leia smiling back at her and
Rey responds to the woman Rey Skywalker
now Rey of course is genetically a
Palpatine but no one wants to be a
Hitler the rise of Skywalker is a film
about identity how each of us enter the
world carrying scars from wars fought in
ages past and those warts continue to
fight within us as they grapple for
which side of that legacy wins out in
future generations which story will our
descendants tell ray began her journey
anonymous the last Jedi suggested that
her parents were nobodies but in the
rise of Skywalker she learns that she's
actually the heir to the most important
man in the history of the galaxy but her
parents and trying to protect her left
her with the gift of freedom from that
past and the gift of a choice to forge
her own identity and that identity that
she chooses is the family that had a far
greater impact on her worldview the
final image of this nonology solidifies
that choice with rey watching the same
binary sunset that Luke Skywalker
longingly gazed upon in the first film
also the image that closed out the
prequel trilogy this is a kind of
rhyming poetry that George Lucas always
hoped for the duality theme reflected in
the two setting stars one framing the
hero the other framing the droid that
rescued her from that anonymity and
brought her into her identity comment
down below with your thoughts on this
ending was it as mind-blowing for you as
Kevin Smith suggested it would be course
your mind still fully intact but like
older and wiser or do you hate
everything and he refused to even watch
this movie because you declared war on
Disney a few years ago just to win over
a few other bros on 4chan who don't
really give a about you if so cool
follow me on Instagram and Twitter I da
vas follow the new rock stars and
socials and subscribe to new rock stars
or breakdowns of everything you love go
on
subscribe do it